[موسيقى]
لا يمكن معالجه الاوضاع الجديده بالطرق
القديمه اننا رمز للتغيير تصريح لم يصدر
عن مسؤول روسيا او صيني بل اطلقه وزير
الخارجيه الهندي في احد الاجتماعات
التحضيريه لقمه دول مجموعه البريكس التي
تعقد الثلاثاء في جنوب افريقيا مؤكدا ان
العالم متعدد الاقدام تصريح لافت من حليف
استراتيجي لقوى الغرب على راسها الولايات
المتحده يعكس تململا عالميا من الهيمنه
الغربيه والامريكيه تحديدا على الهيئات
الاقتصاديه وحتى السياسيه العالميه مجموعه
البريكس التي تضم خمسه دول هي روسيا
والصين والهند والبرازيل وجنوب افريقيا
والتي تعد اقتصاداتها الاسرع نموا بدات
كفكره طرحت قبل 22 عاما وصارت واقعا على
الساحه الدوليه وقد اظهرت قرابه 40 دوله
اهتماما بالانضمام الى المجموعه التي لا
يخفي مسؤول دولها
الى كسر الهيمنه هيمنه الدولار على
المبادلات التجاريه الدوليه وطموحهم الى
اصدار عمله موحده في قصتنا البريكس الرهان
الصعب نرصد ظروف تاسيس هذه المجموعه من
خلال لقاء خصنا به صاحب الفكره اللورد جيم
اونيل المسؤول السابق في مؤسسه جولدمان
سكس زارع بذره البريك الذي بات بريكس
بانضمام جنوب افريقيا اليه لاحقا يشرح لنا
كيف استشرف الحاجه الى بناء نظام اقتصادي
افضل ووجهه نظري حول مستقبل التجمع اقصد
ايضا مع خبراء ومسؤولين من مشارب مختلفه
تطور مجموعه البركس وطموحات اطرافها
والتحديات التي تواجه عملها هذا التكتل
نستكمل بقيه القصه مع سيف الدين قداش
الكاتب الصحفي والباحث في الاقتصاد
والجيوبوليتيك وجيمس ريكرز خبروا الاقتصاد
العالمي ومحرر نشره الاستخبارات
الاستراتيجيه الماليه نحاول مع ضيفين
الكريمين لاستقراء ما قد تسفر عنه قمه
البريكس المرتقبه من قرارات قد تعزز من
مكانته على الساحه العالميه عن مواقع دول
عديده للانضمام الى هذا التجمع ومنها دول
حديثه للولايات المتحده وعن فرص كسر
الهيمنه الغربيه والدولار الامريكي على
المؤسسات الاقتصاديه والتعاملات الماليه
الدوليه عن امكانيه تخطي التجمع حدوده
ككيان يمزج ما بين الاقتصاد والسياسه
ليبرزك قوه الجيوسياسيه تسهم في التوازنات
العالميه الجديده المرتقبه لكن ما رايكم
بدايه ان نشاهد القصه وبعدها الحوار
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الذي انطلقت فيه الطائرات
الامريكيه تقصف صحراء افغانستان بعد هجمات
الحادي عشر من سبتمبر عام 2001
كان هناك في احدى المؤسسات الاستثماريه
الامريكيه من يرى المشهد من زاويه اخرى لا
علاقه لها بتنظيم القاعده او محاربه
الارهاب
لعب هذا الرجل بالاحرف الاولى لاربع دول
تحقق معدلات نمو عاليه بفضل وفره الموارد
الطبيعيه وانخفاض تكاليف العماله وتشكل
التركيبه السكانيه الملائمه فراى امكانيه
تحويل صعودها الاقتصادي القوي الى فرصه
استثماريه كبرى للمستثمرين الدوليين
فصك مصطلحا جديدا من الاحرف الاولى لتلك
الدول
البرازيل روسيا الهند الصين بريك
[موسيقى]
مع
فكره ترجع الى عام 2001 حيث ولدت من رحم
احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر عندما توصلت
لاستنتاج غريب وربما الى فكره مفادها ان
العالم سوف يستمر في عولمته ولكنه لن
يستمر في الخضوع الى الامركه بعد ذلك
بشهرين كتبت تقريرا بعنوان العالم يحتاج
الى بناء اقتصادي افضل
التقرير في جوهره يهدف الى منح مساحه اكبر
لدول بريك في الحوكمه العالميه البرازيل
وروسيا والهند والصين
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي بمؤسسه
مصطلح بريك ليشير الى البرازيل والهند
وروسيا والصين كمجموعه من الاقتصاديه
الناشئه لديها قدره كبيره على النمو
مستقبلا وتوقع انها ستشكل جزءا لا يستهان
به من الاقتصاد العالمي بحلول عام 2050
في العشرين من سبتمبر عام 2006 وعلى هامش
اجتماعات الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في
نيويورك عقد اول اجتماع لوزراء خارجيه
روسيا والصين والبرازيل والهند ليعلن عن
بدايه تعاون مشترك بين تلك الدول
وفي يونيو عام 2009 بعد عام واحد من
الازمه الماليه العالميه عقدت اول قمه
للمجموعه في روسيا واصدرت المجموعه بيانا
ختاميا ذكر ان الدول الاربع ناقشت سبل
الخروج من الازمه الماليه كما توافقت على
الرغبه في مزيد من التنسيق والتعاون من
اجل خلق نظام عالمي اكثر عدلا بحسب ما
قاله الرئيس الروسي انذاك بمتر
ثم انضمت اليها دوله جنوب افريقيا في
نهايه عام 2010 ليضاف حرف الاس الى كلمه
بريك لتصبح بريكس
[موسيقى]
جنوب افريقيا لمجموعه بريك بشكل رسمي عام
2011 ليبلغ عددها خمسه اعضاء ممثلين لدول
الجنوب في كل من افريقيا وامريكا
اللاتينيه واسيا واوروبا من اجل العمل
كوحده واحده وليتغير اسمها
واهميه تكتل بريكس في تمثيله اكثر من
اربعين بالمئه من سكان العالم وثلث مساحه
الارض واكثر من 25% من الناتج المحلي
العالمي
واكثر من 20% من الصناعه العالميه
هذه المجموعه من الدول لا تتشارك في كونها
تحقق معدلات نمو الاقتصادي عاليه فحسب
ولكنها تتشارك ايضا القدره على اداره
سياستها الخارجيه بصوره مستقله بعيدا عن
سياسه الغرب
[موسيقى]
هذه الدول ايضا لديها وجهه نظر مشتركه ترى
ضروره الحد من هيمنه الولايات المتحده على
النظام المالي والاقتصادي العالمي
لا توجد عوامل مشتركه بين مكون بريكس
يمكننا ان نعتبره حاله من الاندماج لان
هذا صعب جدا لاعتبارات كثيره
فالذي يجمع هذا التجمع الان انه اتى في
اطار ما يسمى التكتلات الاقتصاديه في اطار
منظومه العولمه ولكن سمت اختلافات كبيره
بين مثلا توجهات البرازيل فيما يتعلق ببعض
القضايا الاقتصاديه
وتوجهات الصين وكذلك الامر بالنسبه للعند
توالت قمم بريكس وانتظمت بشكل سنوي حتى
جاءت القمه السادسه في يوليو عام 2014 في
البرازيل لتمثل خطوه مهمه على مسار
المجموعه حيث اعلن عن توقيع اتفاقيه بين
الدول الخمس لانشاء مؤسستين ماليتين هما
بنك التنميه الجديد وصندوق الاحتياطات
وصورت الوثائق الرسميه الصادره عن القمه
المبادرتين على انهما تكملان المؤسسات
الماليه والاقتصاديه العالميه والاقليميه
القائمه
افاقا امام الاقتصاديات الناشئه للمشاركه
برايها واعطاها الحق في تصحيح وتغيير
السياسات التي تحدد ما هي الدول التي
يمكنها الاقتراض
لمارو وما هي الانشطه التي سوف تقوم بها
وكذلك مناقشه وتحسين الشروط عند منح
القروض بالعملات المحليه
مقارنه بتلك الشروط التي تقدم من الشركاء
التقليديين في العالم المتقدم
[موسيقى]
الى الطلاق
لنعم الماضي اعلن بنك التنميه الجديد خطته
الاستراتيجيه للاعوام الخمسه القادمه تنص
الخطه على ان 30% على الاقل من القروض
الجديده ستكون بالعمله المحليه مما يشكل
دفعه كبيره للامام فالصين يمكنها الاقتراب
باليوان والهند بالروبيه ونحن يمكننا
الاقتراض بالريم ولا حاجه لنا للاقتراض
بالدولار ثم تحويل القيمه الى العمله
المحليه والسداد بالدولار فنقع تحت رحمه
تقلبات اسعار الصرف ومعدلات الفائده
[موسيقى]
يهدف بنك التنميه الجديد البالغ راس ماله
الاولي 50 مليار دولار موزعه بالتساوي بين
الاعضاء الخمسه الى تعبئه الموارد لتمويل
مشروعات البنيه التحتيه والتنميه
المستدامه بدول بريكس وغيرها من
الاقتصادات الناشئه والبلدان الناميه بحسب
الموقع الرسمي للبنك وتنص لائحته
التاسيسيه على عدم امتلاك اي مساهم حق
النقض
كما يهدف صندوق الاحتياطات البالغ موارده
100 مليار دولار الى مساعده الدول على
تخطي اختلالات موازين مدفوعاتها وضغوط
السيوله من خلال قروض قصيره الاجل
وعلى الرغم مما اعلن من انهما مكملان
للمؤسسات الماليه والاقتصاديه العالميه
فانهما يعملان وفق سياسات مختلفه عن
المتبعه في البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد
الدولي
جزء كبير من دول الاقتصاديات الناشئه يرى
ان صندوق النقد الدولي يصعد دائما
لاجبارها على التقشف وتقليل النفقات
والتصرف وكانها مثل سويسرا او المانيا لذا
تعتقد هذه الدول ان صندوق النقد الدولي
ينفذ اوامر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صاحبه النصيب الاكبر من اسهم الصندوق حتى
يظل دائما تحت السيطره
الامر ليس بهذه البساطه فبالرغم من ان
الاقتصاد علم اجتماعي فانه مع مرور الوقت
ستتضح لك الامور فاذا لم تكن تعمل وفق
اطار اقتصادي مستدام موثوق به فسينتهي بك
الامر بالوقوع في ازمه من نوع ما انس
[موسيقى]
اناره
الدول للخضوع لبعض الاشتراطات مثل
الشفافيه ومكافحه الفساد وتنفيذ المشروعات
وفقا للمعايير البيئيه
اما بالنسبه لصندوق النقد الدولي فعندما
تمر الدوله بازمه ما يقوم الصندوق بمنحها
تمويلا قصير الاجانب ولكن على الدوله ان
تغير بعض السياساتها مثل السياسه الضريبيه
وعجز الموازنه والانفاق العام وكذلك تغيير
سياساتها الماليه بخفض معدلات الفائده حتى
يتاكد الصندوق من قدرته على الخروج من
الازمه وذلك قبل ان يمنحها القرض
اما طريقه بريكس فهي تمنح الدول الناميه
استقلاليه كبيره في قراراتها فلا الصين
ولا الهند ولا اي دوله من اعضاء بريكس
تطلب من الدول في افريقيا او امريكا
الجنوبيه او اسيا تغيير سياساتها الداخليه
او اجراء اصلاحات حتى تستطيع الحصول على
القرض
منظومه البنك وصندوق الدوليين يملكان
تاريخا كبيرا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وحتى الان في تمويل الدول الاوروبيه ثم
تمويل باقي الدول الناميه والاقل نمو
فبالتالي نحن امام منظومه كبيره من حيث
الخبره الاقتصاديه من حيث الممارسه
التنمويه من حيث المعرفه لمشاكل الدول
وطريقه التعامل معها نعم هناك مطالبات
بتطوير عمل البنك والصندوق الدوليين ولكن
البديل لم ياتي بعد حتى يمكن ان نقول انه
افضل من البنك او من الصندوق الدوليين
ظلت بريكس مجموعه مغلقه على نفسها حتى
الرابع من سبتمبر عام 2017 عندما طرحت
الصين في القمه السنويه التاسعه التي عرضت
بها خطه
تحت شعار شراكه اقوى من اجل مستقبل اكثر
اشراق بهدف اضافه دول جديده للمجموعه
وحضرت القمه بعض الدول بصفه مراقب وفي
سبتمبر عام 2021 انضمت بنغلاديش والامارات
والارجواي ومصر لبنك التنميه الجديد ثم
اعلن الرئيس الروسي بوتين في يونيو 2022
عن توافق الدول الخمس على فتح باب العضويه
للاعضاء الجدد
مالتي
[موسيقى]
لدينا دول مثل اندونيسيا وماليزيا
والسعوديه والجزائر ومصر والارجنتيني
اذا نظرنا الى تعداد هذه الدول نعم هي دول
ناميه لكن لديها اشياء مميزه تستطيع منحها
للبريكس مما سيعزز المجموعه بل يمنحوا دول
الجنوب مزيدا من القوه خصوصا انها دول
منتجه للنفط وتحديدا ايران والسعوديه
عدد من الحوافز وعدد من المنافع الممكن ان
تحصل عليها دول العربيه
اولا
تعطي اليوم الخيار
للدول استعمال عملتها الوطنيه وليس
استعمال الحصري للدولار في التبادل
التجاري
ثانيا هناك مركز تمويل جديد خصوصا للبنيه
التحتيه التي تحتاجها هذه الدول ولا تخضع
لفرضيات او لشروق
مساله ان يكون بريكس قدم ناموسا ناجحا لان
يكون بديلا للبنك وصندوق الدولي امامه
تحديات كثيره على راسها مساله الثقه
والشفافيه في النظام المالي للمجموعه ككل
فمثلا حجم القروض التي قدمتها الصين للدول
الناميه والدول الصاعده خلال الفتره
الماضيه لم يعلن عنه بشكل رسمي ولكن هو
متروك للتوقعات هذه واحده الامر الثاني ان
تكتل البريكس لا يقدم
هويه اقتصاديه تختلف عن قواعد النظام
الاقتصاد الراسمالي
[موسيقى]
مع دخول روسيا الحرب ضد اوكرانيا لجات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى الدولار
لاستخدامه كاحد الاسلحه لمعاقبه روسيا
فقامت بالحجز على ارصدتها واستبعادها من
نظام التحويلات العالمي سويفت مما اثار
مخاوفا لدى بعض دول العالم خشيه تعرضها
لنفس العقاب اذا ما خالفت سياساتها سياسات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليعلوا صوت
روسيا مناديه بضروره وجود عمله مستقله
لدول بريس تستخدم في التسويات والتجاره
العالميه وفق تصريح وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجي لافروب في يناير 2023 بان مساله
اصدار عمله موحده
ستناقش في جنوب افريقيا في القمه التي
ستعقد في الثاني والعشرين اغسطس من عام
لقد بدانا النقاش بالفعل
فبالاضافه الى اهتمام بريكس بالنظام
العالمي غير العادل هناك ايضا النظام
المالي غير العادل
مؤخرا عندما ناقش الرئيس الكيني ويليام
روتو هذه المساله طرح سؤالا اذا كانت
كينيا تتاجر مع جيبوتي فلماذا تتاجران
بالدولار لماذا لا تتعاملان بعملتيهما
المحليتين
نعم يمكن عمل تسويه ثنائيه تقلل من
الاعتماد على الدولار لكنني لا ارى
امكانيه استبداله تماما في المستقبل
القريب
كي تقوم بذلك يجب ان يكون لديك رصيد
احتياطي كاف من العملات الاجنبيه العالميه
للمتعاملين الدوليين كما يجب ان يكون لديك
اسواق ماليه مستقره تملك اصولا حتى تتمكن
الدول الاخرى من الاستثمار او سحب الاموال
في اي وقت تشاؤوا انفاقه كما تشاء
حينما نرى مساهمات الدولار في كافه
التسويات الماليه والتجاريه العالميه نجده
في المقدمه ما بين 55 وستين في المئه ثم
اليورو بحدود عشرين في المئه ثم بعد ذلك
العملات الاخرى مثل الجنيه الاسترليني او
الين الياباني او اليوان الصيني الذي لا
يحود اكثر من ثلاثه ثلاثه ونصف في المئه
من حجم التعاملات الماليه والتجاريه على
مستوى العالم
هناك تحدي كبير امام العمله الجديده هل
تتمكن من ان تبقى وتحافظ على قيمتها
احتمال كبير اذا غطيت بالذهب وحفظ على
قيمتها من ان تلعب هذا الدور واذا لعبت
هذا الدور فقدرتها على ان تكون العمله
المقبوله في التعامل وعلى الحفاظ على
الثروه سيعطيها القدره على استبدال قسط
كبير من الدول
انا لست متاكدا من امكانيه تحقيق ذلك
اليورو عمله موحده للعديد من الدول
الاوروبيه التي تتشارك في التوقيت والموقع
فكيف يمكن اصدار عمله لدول بريكس التي تقع
في اماكن مختلفه من العالم وتحكمها انظمه
مختلفه كليا
من سيكون محافظ البنك المركزي لعمله بريكس
هل ستصبح دوله واحده الفكره نظريا مدهشه
لكنها جامحه
متعدده التي تتميز بها مجموعه بريكس والتي
مكنتها من منافسه مجموعه دول السبع
الصناعيه الكبرى بل التفوق عليها بحسب
تقرير مؤسسه اكرون للاستشارات
تواجه العديد من التحديات التي ياتي على
راسها تحقيق التوافق في ظل اختلاف نظم
دولا حتى تتمكن من المشاركه الاقتصاديه
العالميه في وقت يتخوف فيه الغرب من
منظومه قد تؤسس لنظام عالمي جديد
اجمع الدول بريكس تواجه التحديات التي
تعترضها بامال وخطط طموحه لاعاده هيكله
النظام العالمي ولو على المدى البعيد ابدو
هذا من التصريحات والاجواء المحيطه
بانعقاد قمه دول المجموعه غدا الثلاثاء في
جنوب افريقيا وفي تقرير حمل عنوان هل
تستطيع روسيا والصين بث روح جديده في
البريكس قالت مجله الامريكيه ان قمه
المجموعه تذكر بايام انعقاد مؤتمر انضم في
خمسينيات القرن الماضي عندما التقى قاده
29 دوله من اسيا وافريقيا والشرق الاوسط
لتاسيس حركه عدم الانحياز خلال الحرب
البارده وقد دعت جنوب افريقيا قاده 67
دوله من افريقيا والجنوب العالمي بالاضافه
الى 20 ممثلا عن منظمات دوليه دعتهم الى
اجتماعات في اطار قمه جوهانسبورغ التي
ستركز على تحميق الشراكه بين دول البريكس
وافريقيا وتعزيز النمو المتبادل وتحقيق
المستدامه وتقويه الشموليه والتعدديه
تقدمت 23 دوله بطلبات رسميه للانضمام الى
مجموعه البريكس ستبحث قمتها نموذج التوسيع
ومبادئه ومعاييره من بين الطالبيه العضويه
دول عربيه هي الجزائر
والسعوديه البحرين فلسطين الكويت مصر
والامارات
وصرح وزير الخارجيه الروسي بان انضمام
السعودي والامارات والجزائر ومصر الى
المجموعه بما لهذه الدول من ارث حضاري
حربي واسلامي هذا وقالت ديلماروسيف رئيسه
بنك التنميه الجديد ان العالم يميل نحو
التعدديه القطبيه عوضا عن القطبيه
الاحاديه القائمه على الدولار اوساف اوضحت
ان البنك الذي اسسته دول البريكس يهدف الى
زياده نسبه التمويل بالعملات المحليه الى
30% في خمس سنوات لمواجهه هيمنه الدولار
العالميه هذا وقد اتخذت الدول الجنوب
العالمي خطوات لادخال بدائل لنظام التجاره
القائم على الدولار فقد اتفقت الصين
والبرازيل مثلا على استخدام عملاتهم
الخاصه في المبادلات التجاريه بينهما كما
دعا الدول الاسيان الى بدائل للتجاره
القائمه على الدولار اما روسيا والهند فقد
انخرطت فعلا في التجاره باستخدام عملاتهم
الخاصه
ايضا بصدد فعل الشيء نفسه اما هي يا ترى
ابعاد هذه التحولات ومالتها
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفينا
الكريمين من الجزائر السيد سيف الدين قداش
الكاتب الصحفي والباحث في الاقتصاد
والجيوبوليتيك ومن بورس موث بولايه
نيوهامشاير جيمز الخبير الاقتصادي ومحرر
نشره الاستخبارات الاستراتيجيه الماليه
لعنا نبدا معك سيد سيف الدين قداش غدا
تنطلق قمه البريكس في جوهانسبر كما ذكرنا
شعارها الاكبر بريكس وافريقيا والسؤال
حقيقه الليله كدول العربيه ودول افريقيه
تقع فيها هذه القمه وتحمل شعارها ايضا في
تقديرك ما الذي يمكن ان تحمله هذه القمه
لدول القاره خاصه من السعين الى الانضمام
لمنظمه البريكس في ظل الظروف
الراهنه العالميه نتحدث عن توتر بين الصين
والولايات المتحده ونتحدث ايضا عن صراع
للغرب مع روسيا
مساء الخير مساء النور والضيفي الكريم
ولجميع مشاهدي قناه الجزيره
اعتقد بان التحولات الدوليه المستجده على
مستوى العالم قد فرضت بشكل او باخر على
افريقيا ان تبحث عن حلول جديده لوضعها
الاقتصادي ووضع التنميه المستدامه على
مستوى دولها الافارقه امنوا بان البحث عن
معطيات او تحولات فعليه بالنسبه
الاقتصادهم ولوضعهم الاجتماعي يحتاج الى
التنويع والشمول خاصه وانه بعد اكثر من 60
عاما على استغلال اغلب الشعوب الافريقيه
لم يحدث اي تحول فعلي على مستوى التنميه
ولا تزال القاره تعيش الفقر والبؤس والوضع
الصحي المتفاقم خاصه في منطقه الساحل
وجنوب بالصحراء ووسط القاره الافريقيه
اعتقد بان اللقاء البريكس على مستوى جنوب
افريقيا سيحمل معطيات جديده للقاره خاصه
بعد لقاء الرئيس الصيني شي بالافارقه
ولقاء الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ايضا
بالافارقه في القبه الاخيره بحيث ان
الدولتين تملكين القدرات الاستراتيجيه
المتعلقه بمسائل الامن في قضيه او بالنسبه
لروسيا التي يمكنها ان توفر السلاح للدول
الافريقيه لمجابهه التحديات الامنيه التي
تعيشها وهو ما تحدث عنه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديم بوتين وايضا يمكن
روسيا ايضا ان تساعد في تنميه الانتاج
الزراعي وهي من كبار منتجي الحبوب في
العالم ومصدريه ب 60 مليون طن سنويا
بدورها الصين من خلال الانشاءات ومن خلال
قدراتها الماليه الاستراتيجيه والاحتياط
المالي الضخم والتبادلات التجاريه بينه
وبافريقيا وايضا توجهها الصناعيه الضخم
واستهلاكها الكبير للموارد الاوليه والنفط
والغاز يمكن ان تساعد افريقيا في بناء
رؤيه استراتيجيه جديده لاستغلال
عليها على مستوى
بلدانها يمكن ان تساهم في تطوير الانتاج
الصناعي وتطوير الانتاج الزراعي توفير
المخصبات وهو ما يحدث على مستوى الجزائر
باستثمار ضخم بسبعه مليار دولار امريكي
لانتاج الفوسفات وتصديرها من خلال ميناء
عنابه هناك استثمارات للبنى في التحتيه
ايضا تقوم بها الصين في كل من انغولا
وزامبيا وكينيا وغيرها تساهم بشكل او باخر
في رفع الغبن على الشعوب الافريقيه وحلحله
اوضاعها التنمويه
الظروف الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه المواتيه
ثاني تحويل السيد جيمس وقد استمعنا لما
ذكره ضيفنا الكريم من الجزائر سيف الدين
قداش لا شك ان
روسيا وحتى الصين بحثت منذ زمن عن موطئ
قدم في القاره الافريقيه الولايات المتحده
حاولت استدراك الامر قمه امريكيه افريقيه
كانت في ديسمبر 2022 البعض لاعبا في الوقت
بدل الضائع هل باعتقادك بالفعل هذه القمه
التي تنعقد غدا تحت هذا الشعار لافريقيا
ربما تنظر اليها الولايات المتحده بعين
الريبه ام ماذا اشرح لنا كيف تنظر اليها
خاصه وان في هذه القمه هناك رغبه من عشرات
الدول وليس في افريقيا فقط دول الجنوب
العالمي ممن ترغب في الانضمام الى تجمع
فيما قرئ لدى كثيرين كسر محاوله لكسر
الهيمنه الامريكيه على التعاملات الماليه
والاقتصاديه العالميه
نعم
الفوسفات والنفط والحبوب وهذه القضايا
والسلع مهمه لالغاء واعتقد انها سوف تكون
على جدول الاعمال اما تركيزي فسنصبه على
قضيتين اساسيتين مهمتين
مرتبطتين بهذه القضايا الاخرى اولا قضيه
الاعضاء الجدد في البريكس وثانيا قضيه
العمله الجديده التي يمكن ان تصدرها
هذان امراني اساسيان مهمان ومرتبطين
ببعضهم البعض وكما قيل في السابق هنالك 65
دوله دويت لهذه القمه
وهذا شبيههم بالجميع العامه لاولى المتحده
وسوف يكون هناك دول مراقبه ايضا من منظمات
متعدده الاطراف بما في ذلك الامم المتحده
لذلك هذا اللقاء ولقاء مهم وبخلاف ذلك
هنالك عشرون دوله اشارت الى انها
والانضمام الى سبع عود دولنا قدمت الطلب
رسميا بالفعل واهمها الجزائر الجزائر مهمه
للغايه ولكن السعوديه العربيه ايضا تحتل
المرتبه الاولى من وجهه نظري من حيث
الاولويه وجزء من السبب هو ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
لديه الكثير من النفط سيما فيما يخص الصين
الصين تشتري الكثير من النفط من السعودية
للعربيه اكثر من اي دوله اخرى وروسيا
والسعوديه العربيه الدوله التانيه من ثلاث
دول تحتل المرتبه الثلاثه الاولى من ناحيه
تصدير النفط اذا اذا ما كان هنالك منبر
بين السعوديه العربيه وروسيا للعمل على
هذا فسوف تكون الاوبك اهم منذ قبل
وبالتالي دخول المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى البركسا مجددا مع وجود الصين وهي طبعا
مورد للنفط والصين مستورد له فهذا سوف
يزيد من قوه اما بالنسبه للبرازيل
البرازيلا رمت بعض العصي في الدواليب
لانها لم تكن سعيده
بما يجري لان البرازيل كما تعرفون سوف
تكون قوتها مشذبه او مخففه اذا ما حصل ذلك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه يمكن ان تدخل
الى هذا النادي او هذا التكتر ولكن سوف
نعرف ذلك في يوم الخميس عندما تنتهي القمه
وعندما نصل الى الختامي
دعني اعود لسيد نور الدين عفوا السيد سيف
الدين قداش ضيفنا الكريم
[موسيقى]
نقطه مهمه المتعلقه بانضمام هذه الدول
النفطيه الكبرى تحدث عن السعوديه لكن بعض
الخبراء حتى في فيلم الليله تحدث عما يمكن
ان تحمله كقوه هذه الدول النفطيه يتحدث عن
السعوديه عن ايران عن الجزائر ما يمكن ان
تحمله للبلكس السؤال ماذا يمكن ان يحمل
الى هذه الدول ما الذي تسعى اليه ما
الاضافه التي سيقدمها اليها مع مختلف
التباينات بين الدول
ونتكلم عن استراتيجيه البترو دولار نحن
اليوم بصدد اعاده جدوله او بناء نظام
اقتصادي جديد يحتاج ايضا لكسر الهيمنه
الامريكيه التي يعتبر فيها الدولار يشكل
11% من التجاره العالميه البالغه 25
تريليون دولار امريكي وبالتالي فان توازن
القوى والتوازن المصالح والحصول على
الموارد الاوليه يعتبر استراتيجيا
قاعده صناعيه وقاعده زراعيه واضح لكن هناك
من يرى بان ربما من المبالغه الاعتقاد
بانه يمكن بالفعل كسر وتحدي الهيمنه
الغربيه والامريكيه تحديدا
اقتصاديا نعم لكن سياسيا ايضا في ظل هيمنه
الدولار
اليورو ايضا على المؤسسات الدوليه وهما
يتصدران المعاملات الدوليه نهيك عن
الموضوع
السياسي يعني هل من السهل باعتقادك بالفعل
ان تكسر الهيمنه الغربيه في ظل العديد من
علامات الاستفهام او حتى ربما التوترات
الموجوده مع الغرب ككتله ومع اقطاب بعض
اقطاب على الاقل تجمع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قوه عسكريه
واقتصاديه وسياسيه مهيمنه ولدي قدرات
استراتيجيه كبرى ليس من البسيط بين ليله
وضحاها كسر الهيمنه الامريكيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تستعمل قوه العسكريه
وقوتها الاقتصاديه وقوتها السياسيه لتعزيز
الهيمنه نلاحظ في عديد المحاور ومن بينها
المحيط الهادي السعير الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لتجديد اطر الحرب البارده من
جديد من خلال اقامه الاحلاف العسكريه
وغيرها وبالتالي فان اليوم العالم يعمل
بشكل او باخر لتطوير بنيوي جديد للنظام
الاقتصادي العالمي بعيدا عن الهيمنه
الامريكيه وبعيدا عن المصالح الامريكيه
لان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عندما
بنتصاديه العالمي بناته على مستوى مصالحه
الاستراتيجيه لم تعبئ به لا بالاوروبيين
كما فعل
النيكسون مع الاوروبيين وخاطب وزير
الخزانه لديه انذاك الاوروبيين الوزراء
الماليه الاوروبيين عندما امتعظوا من
تحويل الدولار الامريكي او ارتباطه بالذهب
الى
بقائه متحررا وربطه
بالبترول بانها هذه عملتنا وتلك مشكلتكم
وبالتالي فان العالم اجمع حتى الاتحاد
الاوروبي صنع عملته
منفصله عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الاوروبيون انفسهم يعانون من السياسات
الامريكيه في مساله الغاز في مساله الوضع
الاجتماعيه الان نتيجه السياسات الامريكيه
في اوكرانيا وتوجهاتها الاستراتيجيه وخدمه
مصالحها راينا كيف تعاملت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع فرنسا في مساله
الغواصات وغيرها من الاسلحه بايزاء
استراليا عندما كان الطلب موجودا لدى
فرنسا لاستراليا واعطت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه غواصات نوويه وبالتالي فان
الكثير حتى الحلفاء حلفاء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يمتعظون من سياساتها
نقطه مهمه جدا اسمح لي السيد قداش انقلها
الى ضيفنا السيد ريكانز هناك امتعاد حقيقي
من هذه الهيمنه الامريكيه الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه ليس فقط من هذه الدول التي
تحاول ان تكتل في بريك لكن حتى من الحلفاء
الهند وهي واحد من حلفاء الولايات المتحده
كما كان يتحدث ايضا عن فرنسا التي لم
يتوانى رئيسها من زياره الصين لادراكه
باهميه هذا العملاق الاقتصادي ايضا
والسؤال لماذا اختارت الولايات المتحده
اسلوب المواجهه بدل الاحتواء او ربما
التعامل مع مختلف الدول فكره التكتل
وصاحبها الذي تحدث الينا اللورد
تدعو الى هيكل اقتصادي عالمي افضل ومنح
الدور اكبر من وجهه نظري للحوكمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه لروسيا والصين
والبرازيل والهند قبل ان انضمام طبعا
الجنوب افريقيا اليها لاحقا لكن كما ذكرنا
الولايات المتحده اختارت المواجهه لماذا
المتحده الامريكيه لم تبحث ذلك قلت في عام
تخطيط لغزوه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اذا لم تتفق السعوديه مع البترو دولار
فالمملكه
كانت مستعده لغزو وهذا طبعا الجهه
المقابله للتعامل مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك
قلقة العسكريه الامريكيه ولكن ما من مزيج
مرتبط بالبريكسا ودول الناميه
والجنوب العالمي لتدمير الدولار يمكن ان
تدمر الدولار بنفسها وهي فعل ذلك عندما
استغلته كسلاح وكما تعرفون الفتره دولار
وهذه الصفقه تعود العام 1974 ولم يكن هناك
سبب للاخلال بها ولكن لو تتحدى الامريكيه
فرضت عقوباته على المصرفي المركزي الروسي
وعلى الصين ايضا وحضرت توريد التقنيات
العاليه وايضا المعادن الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه والكثير من العقوبه الاخرى فرضتها
الامريكيه اذا لم تستخدم
سلاحه فلم يكن هنالك ممانعه اذا مصحه
تعبير بعيدا عن الدولار ولكن لانها فعلت
ذلك فان المملكه العربيه السعوديه وتركيا
والارجنتين والجزائر يقولون لماذا اذا لم
طرق سياساتنا
اذا هنا ياتي
وياتي وتاتي العمله الموحده
وفي التقرير كان هناك حديث عن بيع النفط
الى الهند والحصول على الاوروبيه ولكن
الروبيه يمكن ان تستخدم فقط في الهند واذا
كان الامر متسابق مع العمله يريدها
والعمله السعوديه فيمكن
انفاق هذه العملات في البلدين فقط ولكن
اذا ما توسعت البريكس فسيكون الامر مختلفا
وفجاه يمكن الحصول على الروبيه او الحصول
على الريال او الحصول على الجوال ولكن
يمكن
انفاقها اذا ما كان هنالك عمله مرتبطه
بالبرك عمله موحده يمكن انفاقها في 20
دوله عوضا عن دوله واحده وهذا شبيه
باليورو العمله الموحده لاوروبا وهذه ربما
مرتبطه بالسياسه الماليه ان
الاتحاد النقدي الاوروبي ليس لديه
سياسه
ماليه اليونان ليس لها سياسه ماليه مع دول
اخرى ما نحتاجه هو دول متعدده تلتئم لكي
تصل الى عمله الموحده وهذا ما يسعى اليه
بريكس ممتاز هذه النقطه اود ان اتحول
واسمع وجهه نظر السيد سيف الدين قداش
حولها العمله الموحده هذا الطموح الذي قيل
بانه سيطرح ربما في القمه التي تبدا غدا
باعتقادك ما مدى امكانيه ذلك سمعنا
هو زارع بذره البريكس قال بانها فكره
مدهشه فكره العمله الموحده لكنها فكره
مجنونه غير قابله للتحقيق نظرا للتباينات
والاختلافات الموجوده بين الدول في
السياسات نعم لكن الجغرافيا ايضا تلعب
دوره العديد من التباينات باعتقادك ما
امكانيه ربما الوصول الى عمله موحده والى
اي مدى ستكون خيارا مجزيا لمختلف الدول
يعني هناك بانها بانها ستخرج من عباءه
الدولار الى عباءه عمله موحده ربما ستكون
في صالح الاقطاب الكبرى في التكتل اكثر من
الدول الصغرى
هو للتوضيح لضيفكم الكريم بان الهند
تستعمل الروبيه الهنديه مع 18 الدوله من
بينها روسيا ويتم مقاصه التبادلات
التجاريه بين كل من موسكو وليودلهي من
خلال
الروبيه ومن خلال الروبل الروسي بالنسبه
للعمله لعمله البريكس اعتقد بان المساله
ما زالت في بدايتها ويصعب ان تنضج ببساطه
اولا عندما نلاحظ التحول الاقتصادي الذي
حدث في الاتحاد الاوروبي وحدوث اتفاقيه
ماستر في عام 1992 قامت الدول الاوروبيه
بوضع سياسه نقديه واضحه ثم وضع استراتيجيه
المتعلقه بنظام جمركي ايضا موحده في هذا
السياق ثم مضت هذه الدول من خلال تاسيس
البنك المركزي الاوروبي والذي وضع الاسس
الجوهريه التي من خلالها تم ضبط مساله
اليورو والمضي قدما في
التعامل به بدايه من عام 2000 مارس عام
اعتقد بان مساله عمله هي مساله منطقيه الى
حد ما عندما يحدث تحول كبير في بنيه
الاقتصاد المتصل بدول البريكس من خلال وضع
منهجي الاستراتيجيه استعمال والتاسيس
للعمله صحيح هذه الدول قامت
بتاسيس لبنك التنميه الجديد الذي يمكن ان
يمنحها قروض وصندوق ايضا احتياطي للطوارئ
لانقاذ الدول التي يمكن ان تتعرض لوضع
اقتصادي صعب او وضعيه اقتصاديه هشه في هذا
السياق اعتقد بان العمله الان هي او مستوى
التبادل بين دول البريكس يمكن ان يتطور من
خلال المقاصه عبر الايداع في البنوك
المركزيه لهذه الدول عمله الدوله اذا
موضوع العمله قد يحتاج لوقت بالفعل السيد
سيف الدين قداش لكن ماذا عن
التوسعه المنتظره باعتقادك هل سي تم البث
فيها في الايام القادمه التي ستكون انعقاد
القمه فيها ما حظوظ الدول المتقدمه كيف
سيتم اختيارها خاصه في ظل التباينات كما
ذكرنا حتى اقتصاديا لهذه الدول
استراتيجيا نتكلم بان الدول البريكس هي
بحاجه الى الدول الاخرى هذه الدول بحاجه
الى الموارد الاوليه وبحاجه الى مجال
استراتيجي يمكن ان تستفيد منه اولا
للاستفاده من الموارد الطبيعيه لتامين
مصالح الاستراتيجيه عندما نتكلم عن الصين
بالنسبه للحزام والطريق واستراتيجيتها
المتناميه لتحقيق التمدد التجاري في
والنسق العالمي هي بحاجه لحلفاء
استراتيجين وللدول تنضوي تحت لواء البريكس
تستفيد من مميزاته
وامتيازاته المتعدده وبالتالي فان دول
بحاجه لدول تمتلك الموارد الطبيعيه
والموارد الماليه نحن نتكلم عن السعوديه
تمتلك احتياطات ماليه ضخمه تمتلك واحد
تريليون دولار امريكي من الناتج القومي
الاجمالي هذا يؤهلها بشكل او باخر ان تكون
قطبا حيويا بالنسبه لبريكس خاصه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط نتكلم عن الجزائر كبوبه
لافريقيا ومنصه للتصدير للاتحاد الاوروبي
خاصه وان الجزائر لم تستفد من الاتحاد
الاوروبي طيله عشرين عاما والاتحاد
الاوروبي كان يعترفها يعتبرها في اطار
الشراكه الاقتصاديه فقط سوقا لتصريف
منتجاته ومحطه وقود لتحصل على الطاقه
وبالتالي فان التحولات الاقتصاديه اليوم
للدول تجعلها خاصه مع المضايقات الامريكيه
في بحر الهادي وغيرها والمضايقات المتعلقه
بروسيا مع منح اوكرانيا اسلحه متطوره بين
طائره اف 16 من الجيل الجديد اعتقد بان
هذه الدول بحاجه الى ان توسع امتدادها
لتوسع قدراتها الاستراتيجيه توسعه مستوى
تجارتها ولتضع الاطر المؤسسه والتي يمكن
من خلالها ان تمضي قدما لتطوير البريكس
وتجعله فعلا تكتل قادر على مجابات
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني باعتقادك الى اي مدى هذه الخطوه سعي
كل هذه الدول للانضمام الى يمكن ان تدفع
الدول الغربيه لاعاده النظر ربما في
الموضوع برمته تبني ربما السياسات اكثر
اعتدالا لاعاده النظر في بنيه النظام
الاقتصادي العالمي والمنظمات الدوليه خاصه
وان هناك ادراك لحتميه ذلك وهناك من تحدث
عن عام 2050 سنه ربما قد تتغير وتنقلب
فيها الامور
انا قبلت مسؤولين في الباندا والاحتياطي
الفيدرالي والخزانه وتحدثت معهم كما تحدث
معكم وهم لا يفهمون ذلك يمكنكم ان تشرحوا
ذلك لهم ولكن هم لا ياخذون ذلك سوف يحدث
تقدما
اعتقد ان هناك تطورات مهمه اما بنسبه
لثمانيه عشر دوله وهي التي تقبل الروبيه
طبعا هذا ممكن ولكن يمكن ان تستخدم فقط في
الهند الروبيه لا يمكن ان تستخدم في فرنسا
والارجنتين او الجزائر او اي مكان اخر
وهذه النقطه الاساسيه استخدام الروبي محدد
ولكن اتفقوا ان هذا سوف يستغرق وقت لا
يمكن قطع دابر الدولار وضحاها ولكن يمكن
ان نبدا بذلك يمكننا ان تتخذ
الخطوه ولذا
بين عام 1992 و2000 تطور للاتحاد الاوروبي
واتخذ استرق الامر ثمان او تسع سنوات
الوصول الى اليورو ولكن
البنك الجديد بنك التنميه الجديد يمكن ان
يكون بنكا مركزين لا نحتاجه الى سياسه
ماليه نحتاج اساسا نقديه موحده ولكن ليس
لليوان والروبل والروبي
وبذلك لا نحتاج الى سياسه نقديه موحده
لذلك ولكن نحتاج الى اساسا نقديه موحده
للعمله الموحده
للبركس تحت مظله بنك التنميه الجديد ولكن
لا اعتقد انها تتفهم ما يجري من حديث معكم
السؤال الاخير للسيد سيف الدين قداش يعني
كيف ترى اهم التحديات ربما التي تواجه
الان تجمع
البريكس كي تنجح ربما في الضغط لتغيير
بنيه النظام العالمي اقتصاديا نعم لكن
سياسيا ايضا ورب ما اعاده تشكيل ما يقال
عن نظام عالمي جديد يكون اكثر عدلا
وشموليه واقل قطبيه مما هو عليه الان
اعتقد بان اهم استراتيجيه يتعلق بدول
البريكس والتحدي التكنولوجي خاصه مع مدير
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في فرض عقوبات
مشدده على الصين خاصه بالنسبه للرقائق
المتقدمه
وتهديدها الصين خاصه في
مساله ضم تايوان الى الى الصين وتهديد
مصالح الصين في منطقه بحر الصين الجنوبي
يعتقد لان اليوم الملف ملف التكنولوجيا
والصناعات التكنولوجيه المتقدمه هي اكبر
تحدي بالنسبه للدول البريكس خاصه وانا صيد
تستورد اكثر من 430 مليار دولار امريكي من
من الرقائق وبالتالي فان التحول
التكنولوجي بالنسبه لروسيا والصين هو امر
مهم جدا لمجابهه القوى الغربيه مع تطوير
النظام المالي خاصه وان روسيا محرومه من
الرقائق وهي تعتمد في صناعه السلاح على
هذا
باذن الله مع بقيه بقصه جديده الاثنين
القادم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]